Speaker 1: Well, I hope it was a great Passover
weekend for people who celebrate Easter weekend,
etc., except for a lot of people, it wasn't
good.
We had not one, not two, not three, not four,
not five, but 10 mass shootings in the United
States over the Easter weekend, 10 mass shootings,
three of which were prominent enough to make
national news.
But a total of 10 different mass shootings,
some particularly horrible.
And it is yet another reminder of this completely
out of control gun violence problem that exists
in the United States.
I'm going to tell you a little bit about some
of these incidents, so the Guardian reporting
about three of these now, some of these were
not.
These terms are really crazy.
Some of these were not major enough mass shootings
that they got national attention.
Some only got local attention.
The Guardian reporting US rocked by three
separate mass shootings over Easter weekend.
Actually, it was 10 two teenage boys killed
in Pittsburgh in one of at least three shootings
over the weekend, including two in South Carolina.
South Carolina didn't just have one Easter
mass shooting.
They had two Easter mass shootings in Pittsburgh,
two teenage boys killed and eight others wounded
after gunfire erupted at a party in a short
term rental home in Pittsburgh early Sunday.
The other two shootings, both in South Carolina,
left a total of 18 people with bullet wounds.
Once again reigniting calls among advocates
for meaningful gun control legislation.
Now remember at any time, if you're morbidly
curious about the sad state of gun violence
in the United States, you can go to gun violence,
archive.org and on that website.
Not only can you see a list of all recent
shootings, meaning mass shootings and non
mass shootings.
You can also see the mass shooting specifically
and the details.
And as you will see here yesterday, Easter
Sunday, we had a shooting in Pittsburgh, Miami,
Portland, Furman, South Carolina, Sacramento,
California and Philadelphia, Pennsylvania.
Two mass shootings in Pennsylvania yesterday,
one in Philly where four people were injured
and the one I mentioned in Pittsburgh were
two were killed and eight were injured.
On Saturday, the day before Easter, we saw
mass shootings in Syracuse, New York, Baltimore,
Maryland, Columbia, South Carolina and North
Las Vegas, Nevada, and then on Good Friday.
We were lucky enough to have only one mass
shooting in the United States in Stockton,
California.
Now, with any of these on Gun Violence Archive,
you can click on the View incident or view
source information.
So for example, if we look at Miami, it tells
us where the shooting took place and who the
victims were.
Gender, age, etc. and what the circumstances
were.
This one noting that it was a teen party,
a teen party was the location of this shooting.
This is absolutely insane and may be the most
frustrating thing about this is the resignation
with which, you know, it's this we joke where
we haven't tried anything yet and we're all
out of ideas.
We've had all sorts of different proposals.
And I'll be the first to tell you.
I mean, listen.
Number one, we have a Second Amendment.
You're not just going to ban guns.
That shouldn't even be what the left tries
to do because you're not going to do it.
We have a Second Amendment, but we have so
many things that could be done that would
without a doubt reduce the number of shooting
deaths wouldn't eliminate them.
Of course, you're always going to have people
who obtain guns illegally that that's always
the case.
But if there are fewer guns in the system,
there are fewer guns which can be obtained
illegally.
And we saw after the Sandy Hook shooting in
Connecticut during Barack Obama's presidency,
90 percent of the country said, I mean, listen.
Universal background checks a background check
for any gun transaction, even personal transactions.
If I sell a gun to my friend, I should still
have some system where I can easily run a
required background check before I sell them
a gun.
Maybe I don't know everything about my friend.
Limits on ammunition requirements In terms
of insurance, we require insurance in most
states in order to drive a vehicle.
Why wouldn't we require insurance for owning
guns?
What about relicensing?
Not just you do a weekend and get you, then
you get your ID card and that's it.
But relicensing the way we do with driver's
license.
I mean, there's so much low hanging fruit,